I think the panel that Darrell and the
folks here at the Business School have
put together have a broad cross-section
of new responsibilities but let me tell
you two things about them they were all
myself included once working at central
bank's so in spite of their experiences
in the private sector therein you will
find a central bank sort of background
and ethos to this group but the second
thing I'll tell you about this group
might surprise you these guys all want
to fight with each other so we're gonna
try to have a lively lively debate
I think the discussion we had this
morning that David led us through that
Mark talked about began at the immediate
topic of bank capital and bank liquidity
let me try to put that in a slightly
broader context engage the discussion
here by making four points first the
financial architecture is in substantial
flux and I think in Washington at least
we have a tendency to hear a statement
like that and say I yes
that's because the rules of the road the
regulation is in flux and I think that's
part of it myron scholes and I had a
discussion with students yesterday and I
think the point that both of us tried to
make is not only are the rules of the
road in flux but the reaction function
of financial services firms are in some
sense unknown and unknowable in order to
get this all right
not only the rules have to be clear but
the understanding of what that means for
banks and other financial services firms
on a global basis has to be understood
so that the right things can be done for
the global economy so it is this
uncomfortable iteration that I would say
we're in the early early parts of the
business of banking is at an inflection
point I think some of the questions that
are in some ways in the air here include
will the banks at the top become
utilities to one extent or not second
will those banks be in a different tier
will they have a different competitive
environment a different group of
predators than the other 9000 financial
institutions in the US or in fact if we
think of the largest banks the next year
think of those as regional banks and the
next tier think of those as community
banks will those borders among those
tiers be permease will they be poorest
will they be permeable will those that
air at the top fall or will the same
institutions that are at the top today
remain there forever more I think the
implications of that question are likely
to big consequences not just for
regulation but for the broader economy
our banks special we have a tendency in
central bank language to talk about the
banking industry and the theory of that
always was that somehow banks are
special they take retail deposits and
they do special things but the
discussion that Mark led you through on
Basel suggests that maybe it is
financial services firms and the
specialness might not be their ability
to take deposits but it might be whether
they are in the language of the moment
systemically important and I think the
other implication of that is our firms
that are outside the formal banking
sector who might think that they're not
going to be subjected to these rules is
that the direction that the world is
going so the capital and liquidity
discussions that we're having today
strike me as being indicative
illustrative of some of these broader
developments second let me just briefly
try to define what we're talking about
in capital liquidity I think David and
Mark did a did a good job of that this
morning but at some level I think I
would say capital is a kind of insurance
capital should be what absorbs losses
that are unanticipated it's the role of
capital in these financial structures
and I think what surprised many of us in
the Central Bank and regulatory
community in the crisis is that there
was a lot of capital at least by
regulatory standards but it didn't seem
prepared to absorb losses and the
question really is whether that should
count as capital going forward second we
had a bit of a discussion this morning
about what is liquidity
and well I think we can talk about
liquidity as the grease
that helps the engine run I think the
reality at least for those of us that
were hanging around in the darkest days
of the crisis is separating capital and
liquidity as much as we can in some
academic textbook proved difficult so
keeping those definitions separate and
understanding when they conflate and
periods of distress is useful a third
framing point is that we tend to talk in
forums like this and analysts that cover
the banks they tend to talk about levels
of capital and liquidity from a
regulators perspective I think we
probably don't give enough time and
attention to what the right levels of
capital liquidity are through the eyes
of markets and market participants and
if you were to ask me about where the
focus should be I think there's no doubt
that we need regulatory reforms no doubt
that we need greater clarity on what
regulators expect capital and liquidity
to be but that shouldn't be to the
detriment of what market participants
demand of individual institutions and if
we end up in a world of capital
liquidity where regulators are the only
ones setting the rules and market
participants are yielding entirely to
the great wisdom of us in the regulatory
community we will not have the kind of
transparency and market functioning that
we want so I'd put a bit more burden in
our discussions and what a markets think
the right capital and liquidity are for
bank acts for a institution with the
following characteristics and those
judgments ought to be taken into account
when regulators do their job and let me
make a fourth and final framing question
and I think it's one that was made this
morning but I amplify it and that is we
have one imperfectly integrated global
economy we have one imperfectly
integrated set of financial markets and
the idea that any of us no matter how
wise no matter how rigorous our rules
are that any of our banks or financial
institutions or our economies for that
matter are somehow
isolated to the rest of the world is an
error I think many of us that served at
the Fed over the course of the last
several years feel good about one thing
particular and that is maybe a little
bit at our behest in aggregate the US
banking system has recapitalized itself
now it may be that firms would have
recapitalized if they weren't pushed a
little bit by their regulators but I
think all in all we have to feel pretty
good about the massive recapitalization
of our banking system doesn't mean that
the capital levels are exactly right for
everybody but we've got a couple hundred
billion dollars of new common equity
that should make central bankers sleep a
little bit easier in the US and I think
an open question is whether the rest of
the world should feel as comfortable
about the recapitalization of their
banking sectors I think the questions
was raised this morning about whether in
fact they need to raise all this capture
left all after all because if the
sovereign is prepared to stand behind
them there's a difficult and important
question whether the capital
requirements of them should be similar
huge implications of this for the global
economy
so with those for framing points let me
first turn to Adrian and give him the
allotted ten minutes we'll go around the
horn this way and open it up to
questions Adrian I think he said I have
to say I was threatened with physical
violence by one member sitting on this
panel here aren't I I just want him to
know that we astray Lian's are always
travel with a boomerang in our briefcase
I guess so in terms of the the talk but
I wanted to give oh I love this picture
you know the young it was really about a
river where where the bank was
collapsing but I just couldn't resist uh
sticking it in there the I guess you
know we've done a lot of things on
dodd-frank we've done a lot of things on
Basel the G sci fi is still a global
systemically important financial
institutions is still something that
we're discussing at the Financial
Stability Board and so on actually given
what was said by the Fed officials are
smoking I should say the same thing
these are these are my views are not the
Financial Stability boards views or or
the OECD's use I guess the arm I guess
the feeling that I have though is that
that a little bit different to the
introduction
that one of the problems with our
regulation has been that it's been too
far I've seen through the eyes of
private sector participants and not
enough imposed on them in and I'll show
you some of the reasons why I think that
now I've got to move quickly given the
ten minutes what I want to show you here
though is just our derivatives this is
the gross notional derivatives and what
I call in the gray bar primary assets
now that's the thing that actually
finances the economy remember
derivatives don't finance anything they
just shift things around
whereas equities securities are banks
and so on they're actually funding
growth and investment and the like
that's the gray bar and you see there
back in 1998 primary assets or primary
securities were about two times world
GDP were pretty much over this period
they stayed two times world GDP you have
a look at you have a look at derivatives
with the the dotted line there three
times world GDP getting up to the crisis
just before 12 times GDP bit of a
setback and we're running around 10
times GDP at the moment the primary
assets well the banking ones have been
on this steady uptrend are in terms of
the the black line there the equity
market well you can see the effects of
2008 on what happened to equity market
capitalizations and you see there are
dead securities and of course in the
derivatives I love this chart because if
you look at that bottom line look at the
gray one that the c.d.s you know like I
sometimes show that chart on its own and
it's very spectacular chart building up
the sort of sixty trillion and then
having and we know that CD s played such
a big role in the crisis but but but
they don't nothing compared to the
amount of interest rate derivatives out
there he arm now this what I wanted to
do is I apologize for rushing but what I
wanted to do is because a lot of things
are going on here today and maybe we can
leave it to question time but a lot of
things are going on in terms of shifting
derivatives standardized derivatives
onto exchanges where they might be
better better in terms of clearing at
clearing platforms where they might be
better margin and so on compared to the
the fairly sort of gray area of what
happens at the moment what you see here
though is done for those of you who
don't know what a hurt handle index is
it's a it's a measure of concentration
and the typical pattern you see I don't
do it for all the derivatives I have
done so but but you see here what
happens is you
concentration was building up in the
early 1990s then you get this big fall
away as everybody rushed in in terms of
for example into CEOs and you and
derivatives and so on and so entry
happened in the market drives down
margins UBS story is a very good example
of that then of course a lot of people
have to exit the industry and
concentration rises again when you think
about concentration and moving things on
to our clearing houses that
concentration is going to be a factor
and these goals are systemically
important financial institutions are
basically investing in these clearing
houses and will have a big sale on that
now I won't I'll just quickly move to
say to the last one here that I want to
make sure I stay within my ten but when
you can take that person down index
number what this basically shows you is
I'm sure the previous one beyond what
you see here is that you can convert
that F and L index picture of
concentration into the number of banks
that if they had the same I'll share how
many banks would be serving that market
so if you look on the far right-hand
side for example you'll see that with
with the the black line for example us
in the US dollar market options interest
rate options essentially being served by
only six firms and you see there the the
u.s. swaps market by about eight or nine
firms and and so on and so that's how
you interpret that thing so these are
very tough this is for the whole world
so these are very concentrated markets
we're talking about now what's the
problem with concentration and and the
way OTC derivatives work well as we all
know in this room pricing and the
valuing of these things very difficult
but it certainly depends on a diversity
of used the more concentrated you become
the less the worse those views are the
more inefficient pricing is and as
concentration rises in particular since
Basel has nothing to say about sour
concentration it doesn't penalize
concentration we have concerns about
these developments in concentration
these are just explanations of the
barriers to entry are that cause are
this concentration i won't i won't go
into that because of the ten minutes am
i doing cheap I've got halfway through
okay there's that slide again on the
collapsing Bank now what I wanted to do
is just briefly then come to be
to the issue of the of capital and the
Basel requirements because for me
personally I think the biggest problem
and when you read the bank's comments on
Basel one two and three all through the
process here you always see a similar
pattern don't mess with our definition
of what we think is capital don't talk
about leverage ratios don't try and
discuss knitting any problems with
netting derivatives we don't we don't
want you to worry about any of that but
we love risk weighted assets we just
love that we think the bars will tear
ratio is very good we're happy to work
with the BSP be with with regard to that
and of course they would say that
wouldn't they because in my view I'll
skip anything and go well just to give
you an Indus find it was my question to
the Goldmans day today you seem to reply
by the way I don't if you still hear
that these are the winner just to show
you the importance of getting this right
when AIG failed these were the payments
how you can see there in the second last
column these were the payments that were
made by to everyone who's a US citizen
in this room by your government to
settle the positions of these banks and
you notice there that by the way a
majority a majority that money went to
foreign makes a majority of the money
paid by the US to save iog actually went
to foreign banks now the answer I got
about the top point nine from Goldman's
4.1 billion that they received that they
they didn't really need it I guess that
implies that clothes out netting didn't
apply in the case of our the failure of
our Jim I suppose that must be true
given what he said but normally what
would happen is you'd be settling net
positions you know closer and so those
as I understood it were the net
positions and you can see how big they
are but they keep on on the right-hand
side are 29 30 in the case of Deutsche
Bank 37 percent of their equity less
goodwill was paid to them as capital the
alternative position had our G been
allowed to fail what would have happen
to those would happen to those banks
they will be the loss has taken to the
bottom line and that would have become a
problem for all over the of the global
financial system so now when it come to
the question of our basel to finish the
the way Bartha works is it defines
risk-weighted assets up the top there
are you know grossing up the operational
market risk and then doing the some of
the of the way that assets now the
problem with the problem with the basel
system is the Basel has nothing to say
about the ratio of risk-weighted assets
to total assets so if I could just use a
reductio ad absurdum sort of point if
you are able to use the rivets and the
way you arrange your portfolio is to get
your risk weighted assets down to one
euro in the case of a European Bank
which technically you could then you'd
be asked to hold 7% of one euro
you know so 7 cents and that could be
your capital for a two trillion euro
balancing that's a ridiculous example
but that's literally there's nothing to
stop that from happening
so what banks do is they are actually
can incorporate the way they use
derivatives and the way they choose
their portfolio are to minimize the
amount of risk weighted capital that
they have and therefore to because the
the multiple of addicted to calculate
that capital the multiple is all related
assets so if you don't believe me to
show you the two minutes I just want to
show you this maybe I'll just finish
with these last two slides mister shows
you on the left hand side there the
leverage of the Bank shown the way
cherubi to be entirely European banks
are you see they were in basel ii was
introduced remember that was supposed to
make things tougher after Basel 1 now
you see what happened is that um when
Basel 2 was introduced the leverage of
these banks actually accelerated didn't
it didn't decelerate it accelerated if
you look on the right-hand side there
you'll see the ratio of risk-weighted
assets to total assets for those banks
concern banks can at will just reduce
the ratio of respited assets to total
assets by various our portfolio
manipulations and this shows you all of
the banks including US banks where you
have rich graded assets versus total
assets on the vertical and you have the
leverage ratio on the horizontal I need
to see their they line up in a pretty
linear fashion in terms of in terms of
that ratio
finally take me too long to go through
that are the the I guess the the
affected policies the OECD has always
supported had been a leverage ratio
based on no netting of derivatives a GFI
levy which could apply are for
on on some concept of interdependence
you could take that you could take a
derivatives as an example but the one
that I favor and that we said very alone
in the crisis was what we what if you
want to leave it up to the private
sector then our which i think is the
best way to do it then make sure that
you separate those entities that you
have essentially like a Volcker Rule for
all actions with respect to the
interdependence actors in particular our
swaps derivatives and so on that if we
make those separate then even as things
move on to clearing houses and so on
we'll be very sure that when people deal
with each other they know they don't
have access to too big to fail to
implicit or explicit guarantees from the
government they will have to basically
be independently capitalized and you'll
have the appropriate spreads and and
margining requirements that would follow
from that which you make those banks are
much safer much safer places to be
perfect thank you very much Adrian got a
lot cover in ten minutes let's turn to
David who's gonna give us I think a
perspective from Moody's the rating
agencies have been much discussed during
the crisis and some have blamed the
rating agencies for different parts of
it there hasn't seemed to been a
counterbalance blame for those
sophisticated investors who outsource
their due diligence to rating agencies
and so I think David's got a take up
some of the issues we discussed what's
the role of government support as
Moody's thinks about ratings of
financial institutions what's the right
capital and liquidity levels for these
financial institutions not just as set
by regulators but Moody's independent
judgment so turn it over to you thanks
Kevin
and good morning everyone start by
thanking Darryl and the Stanford finance
firm for inviting me here participate in
today's conference definitely promises
to be a lively and day I'm gonna try to
give an overview of how Moody's thoughts
about bank capital liquidity involved in
response to the events of the crisis and
also try to as best I can represent the
views of fixed income investors who are
the main users of Moody's ratings and an
important constituency for us before the
financial crisis generally speaking
capital liquidity were given equal
weight in our analysis with
profitability and asset quality and also
two quantitative factors
we're giving equal weight with
qualitative factors franchise value risk
management regulatory and operating
environment indeed if anything
we probably tended to focus more heavily
on profitability especially relative to
risk weighted assets I'll get to that as
a key measure of bank credit risk since
stable and reliable profits can
represent an important source of future
capital but during the crisis this
source of capital was not available for
many banks given us sizeable and frankly
unexpected losses many banks suffered we
also observed that at the peak of the
crisis in the fall of 2002 vini banks
were able to monetize what were arguably
very strong franchises through the
issuance of new common equity the high
degree of uncertainty among investors as
well as the reluctance of management's
to acknowledge the severity of the
crisis certainly played a role in this
and to make matters worse mark alluded
to this the tendency toward higher
dividend payout ratios before the crisis
and the reluctance of back management's
to cut their dividends early in the
crisis meant that many banks were
depleting their capital by paying out in
dividends far more than they were
earning indeed we did a little study for
the US banking system the amount of
common David Evans paid from the middle
of 2007 to the end in 2008 was almost
half of the amount of common equity was
banks were subsequently forced to raise
in 2009 in response to this in early
2009 Moody's adopt increased its focus
on capital liquidity in its analysis of
banks globally and adopted a more
rigorous approach to scenario analysis
and stress testing to assess how banks
capital liquidity would perform under
both an expected case and a one or more
of stressful scenarios and this
continues to be our focus of this day as
a result of this we had fairly
significant number of rating downgrades
during the spring of 2009 banks mainly
on their more so on their standalone
ratings as Kevin alluded to the support
implicit support much of which at that
point had already become explicit did
provide something of a
a buffer and so that debt and deposit
ratings at that time could not fall as
much although we today see the gradual
removal of support and the changes in
resolution powers occurring in Merrion
countries continues to have downward
pressure on Bank ratings because we
think those support assumptions that we
sustained pre-crisis that we increase
during the crisis are likely not to be
sustainable post crisis regarding the
quiddity we belong viewed unsecured
wholesale funding as notoriously
unreliable whether it be in the form of
CP or wholesale deposits the our rating
methodology is an explicit preference
preference for banks with high levels of
courtesans and liquid assets relative to
wholesale funding we've also looked for
strong liquidity buffers and alternative
sources of funding at any bank that's
reliant on short term unsecured funding
but prior to the crisis we generally
looked for sufficient liquidity or
alternative funding sources so as to
allow a bank to survive the loss of
Capital Markets funding for up to a year
the crisis revealed that markets can
remain shut for longer than that and so
we are now generally looking for larger
liquidity buffers than we were
pre-crisis in this regard we find that
generally speaking the basel acquitting
proposals to be a very positive step for
bank creditors it creates for the first
time actual equity requirements and
something that is relatively uniform
globally although we do fear that in a
long time frame being considered for
implementation this could allow for
these proposals to be watered down
another assumption which the crisis
challenge was the reliability of secured
funding markets previously we considered
secured wholesale funding as a more
reliable and stable source of funding
than unsecured wholesale funding and
indeed as a potential backstop for
unsecured funding our view had been had
been that while haircuts on such funding
would likely increase in times of stress
the funding would still be available but
during the crisis secured funding dried
up almost as quickly as unsecured
funding for many issuers this was
particularly challenging since prior to
the crisis many banks trading portfolios
have grown in
recently large driven in part by a
growing focus on originated to
distribute business models these in
large trading portfolios are funded at
least partially with short term secured
financing such as repo but in hindsight
much of that growth involved less liquid
assets or at least assets for which
liquidity was a function solely of
irrational exuberance the reliance on
short-term secured funding for less
liquid assets proved to be a significant
challenge for many banks our analysis of
secured funding now focuses more closely
on the liquidity and quality of the
collateral banks are relying upon to
secure funding as well as the absolute
level of illiquid assets in the trading
book we're also looking more closely at
the term structure of bank secured
funding even if measured in weeks and
months rather than in years in a stress
scenario of a difference between
overnight repo funding and three month
or six months repo funding can be the
difference between an orderly unwind
positions and a fire sale with the
resulting impairment to both capital and
client confidence another revelation
brought to light by the crisis was the
extent to which Basel risk weighted
assets either Buzzle one or basel two
failed to provide a reliable indicator
of a banks riskiness or the extent to
which a bank might be expected to suffer
greater losses relative to peers this
was most notably the case with the basel
market risk framework indeed in
hindsight the growth in banks trading
books I moved into a moment ago was no
accident instead it appears to be in a
clear case of regulatory arbitrage as
banks took advantage of the fact that
assets in the trading book attracted far
lower risk weights than the same assets
held in the banking book in light of
this the revisions to the market risk
framework under Basel two and a half of
three are clearly positive for creditors
since they should align risk weighted
assets in the trading book and thus
regulatory capital more closely with the
actual risks a bank is taking but
frankly the Basel Committee still faces
a big credibility gap with investors
risk weighted assets remains a very
opaque calculation to outside investors
risk weighted assets
sorry and that opacity combined with its
poor track record of predicting risk
during the crisis has led many investors
to ignore it in favor of simpler balance
sheet measures not the balance sheet
measures are that much more transparent
or comparable across firms so at the end
of the day this opacity is driving many
investors to demand a premium for
investing in banks Moody's continues to
use risk weighted assets and not many of
our analytic ratios we are also
increasingly looking at balance sheet
leverages and added metric balance sheet
leverage not only provides a useful
measure of the size of a bank's capital
buffer against its liabilities which
after all are its obligations to its
creditors but can also be a useful
measure of how vulnerable but Bank may
be to model risk in other words the risk
that banks risk weighted assets our
understanding it's true risk but with
the opacity of banks risk profiles is
not limited to risk weighted assets for
banks with significant capital markets
activities the degree of public
disclosure by banks on their risk
appetite and risk profile is still very
limited
well most banks disclose var the
parameters Y vary widely from bank to
bank and furthermore var by as a very
formulation provides no information
about tail risks so don't even get me
started on trying to understand where a
capital markets firm is making its
profits when most firms disclose a
single line item for fixed income sales
and trading revenues it's pretty much
impossible to know so we still think
thanks basic if you can hurdle this in
terms of regaining market confidence we
think the banks are highly leveraged and
frankly much of the debate around the
right capital ratio was still in thanks
Haley leveraged reliant on confidence
sensitive funding and the tensions
between equity holders and bank managers
versus bondholders the inherent asset
concentrations of many banks it is
difficult to avoid and is not factored
into most Basel measures and the lack of
transparency we find very challenging
and we think continues to make it very
difficult to have confidence in Bank
excellent thank you David turn turn to
add him among Adams response
is that JP Morgan is to think through
how to navigate through both on the
business front and the regulatory front
these issues and with regulators no
doubt spending more time with he and his
colleagues he's at challenges to get
through it and do so in a way in which
confidence is still held in the
institution so turn it to you Adam thank
you
confidence is obviously a very important
thing we like to think that we managed
navigated the crisis relatively well and
hopefully that inspired confidence in in
our management team I wanted to try to
give you a little bit of insight as to
why all these issues matter and how they
course through our organization and then
maybe comment on some of the other
things that have been said today much of
which I actually agree with so every
month my chairman CEO has a meeting with
the CEOs of each of his six business
lines and they go through their
financial performance their risk
performance their control agenda and a
host of other things as part of that
analysis they are meant to discuss how
they're doing with respect to the amount
of equity that is assigned to their
business line and we have a in our
capital management process we have a
methodology for assigning capital to
each business which is based on in part
risk-weighted assets calculations
updated now for Basel three economic
risk capital so we have our own
independent measure of the capital we
need to support our activity rwa
stresses peer comparisons our outlook
and expected losses and loan losses or
coverage as well as the application of
management judgment for example related
to the need to support franchise value
and say an asset management business or
something like that
so each business gets an allocation of
capital if you will and it's translated
into a core amount or equity capital
only it's not reflective of any type of
hybrid instruments then may be allowed
by regulators at the same time we try to
fully load the costs of funding to each
of those business lines so that we we
give funding to assets and we give
credit to business lines that generate
liabilities and we try to do this based
on market of observable factors and we
make this employment structure a legal
entity or otherwise so these are key
components both the capital and the
funding costs of line of business
performance review analysis and it's
used it really courses through the
organization because it flows literally
down to the loan officer who may be
sitting with a CFO in the field who can
they're talking about a credit facility
and he can literally call up the the
cost both of capital and funding for the
type of facility they're discussing so
this is it's almost real-time in in its
flow through the organization it's the
drivers of marginal pricing decisions of
pricing models of portfolio sales and
acquisition decisions so this is very
very important throughout our
organization and it creates a discipline
around financial awareness and
regulatory awareness because most of the
time virtually all of the time the
regulatory requirements exceed our
assessment of the risk even though we
believe we're applying
highly rigorous methods to determine the
risk so what is done in the regulatory
sphere translates directly into the into
the banker activity so against that
background let me just talk a little bit
about what I consider to be the
laboratory that we're in and I think
that's really what it is and many people
have noted this so as a general matter
we are highly supportive of higher
capital requirements stronger liquidity
standards are really the introduction of
liquidity standards because we haven't
had them before in any formal way
certainly the elimination of the
too-big-to-fail notion and we were big
proponents of title 2 of dodd-frank
which has been to get at the resolved
ability of large financial institutions
in an orderly way to echo what Kevin
said however we've done a lot already
19's gap banks have raised actually
three hundred billion dollars of capital
leveraged has been reduced substantially
and if actually the IMF has a great
graph which I should have brought which
shows that US financial institutions are
better capitalized and lower leverage
then than others around the world risky
structures have been virtually
eliminated and importantly we're now
subject to regular stress tests
including what we just went through to
determine whether it was acceptable to
repay dividends or not but also
importantly for our own purposes to be
shared with regulators we do stress
tests on a quarterly basis that captures
the entire institution and we're subject
to review by the supervisors of those
stress tests and have to respond to
their comments and requests for
enhancements so we we've done a lot to
shore up the financial system for
for the future against that background
now we have Basel 3 which represents a
huge increase in capital requirements
and mark touched on and he explained it
well but if you think about it you know
our our basel 1 translation between
Basel 1 and Basel 3 is really where our
Basel 3 7% requirement which is the
capital the minimum capital standard
plus the conservation buffer that mark
talked about it translates into double
digits of Basel on capital requirements
so that's nearly three times the more
than three times the well capitalized
equity standard in the United States so
under under fiducia so we've done a lot
to increase the capital and this
includes the calibration deductions from
capital the definition of capital market
risk capital requirements have been
increased three to four times depending
on who you are and how you measure it
counterparty risk capital increase
substantially and the conservation
buffer gets at the point that starts to
get at the point david commented on
which is the payout of of capital at the
same time that really you probably
should be conserving it so that if you
trip the new high seven percent standard
you have to automatically start
conserving capital so we built that
automatic mechanism so all of this by
the way is being done against a playing
field that is uneven at best and i think
what we're not who's going to get in the
into that a little bit so one of the
things that we're we're concerned about
is how this laboratory i don't think we
understand yet the intersection of how
capital liquidity and leverage will will
work together in these new standards
we're telling banks to hold a lot more
capital but we're requiring them to
self-insure against systemic truly
systemic panic type events as well as
idiot
and Craddock runs new incentives are
being created and banks being economic
animals will be responsive to them so
you know what for example what are the
liquidity standards incenting us to do
or telling us they're saying don't
provide liquidity backstops
in the in the financial system they're
saying don't take wholesale deposits
well that's a primary function of what
we do don't buy anything but
government's you know know nothing and
mark didn't go into a whole lot of
detail but really government securities
are the only thing that counts on a
liquid asset buffer and I think you know
our our sense even through the crisis if
you go look at at the numbers there are
plenty of liquidity in lots of asset
classes besides government's banks will
adjust their balance sheets to the
increased capital requirements and the
new liquidity standards and some will do
for though in very meaningful important
ways the changes will be fast I know the
Basel Committee puts a lot of stock into
the glide path to the implementation of
the standards mark talked about the
observation period that will not happen
banks will respond as soon as the ink
appears to be dry they will be
responsive to that and start managing
that way we are already starting to
manage to Basel 3 standards I know
others will say you know there's there's
no cost to to equity well and that and
team we'll talk about that later I think
David's answer to that question was
right the market determines that I think
you know those who think that ought to
go talk to equity investors as we do
they do not think that there's no cost
to significantly higher capital
requirements and they vote with their
feet and we think that's very very
important it's not clear at all that the
cost of equity what we will be rewarded
with a reduction and the risk premium
whatsoever and we're creating new
incentives along the way including
to take higher potentially higher risks
in order to achieve meaningful returns I
think the answer in the end is a as a
balance as David said we highly
supportive of tough transparent
consistently applied in reasonable
standards and what we want is not to
lose the benefits of a global financial
system in an increasingly global and
interdependent economic world let me
just find conclude if I have a minute
Kevin less than that just on the netting
point you know netting netting works and
it is a true representation of the
credit and liquidity position of the
firm Lehman it proved to be the case and
Lehman there were four distributes
around Lehman none of them have to do
with closeout netting so it's a fair
representation of what the economics are
of a derivative trade which by the way
provides substantial value as many have
noted in our economy thank you thank you
Adam
Turner Raphael who's gonna take us
through a few slides for the invitation
to be here I want to talk about bass and
three and this you may be surprised to
hear that perhaps bass and three needs
some fixing it hasn't been born and I
want to start with two quotations from
the Financial Times the first one is
coming from a letter of Commissioner
hornier
who is the person in charge of financial
markets in the European Union to
secretary Geithner he says the you beat
up and toughened its new banking rules
in order to prevent American Bank from
having an unfair advantage over their
European counterparts well kind of
strong words on the other hand if you
look at this side of the Atlantic there
is also another quotation European banks
have a subjectivity of the risk
weighting system with aggressive risk
calculations is coming from Jamie Dimon
Adams boss and actually these this is
the same concern that they
venire express this morning about level
playing field issues so what's going on
well I think that part of the reason is
that the u.s. didn't implement bustled -
and it's not clear what will eventually
happen with Basel 3 and you did
implement Bassel - and there is a draft
directive for Basel 3 but in a way that
as I will explain leaves much to be
desired
so what I'm going to do here today is to
look at this trust and lacked in debate
on base and three from an academic
perspective and focusing on capital
requirements I guess that I could say
something about the liquidity
requirements but I will don't have the
time to do that I want to argue that the
issue of procyclical ETS is at the core
of the problem you may think that
procyclical it is a boring macro side
effect but I think that project legality
is very important and in particular the
way in which it has or it has not been
addressed by supervisors I want to talk
about what's happened with with weighted
assets in in in recent years and I want
to have a brief comment about the
counter-cyclical capital buffer of Basel
3 to start with something that everybody
knows the structure of capital
requirements you have capital or a risk
weight that Isis has to be greater than
or equal to a minimum so there are three
elements in this formula the numerator
what do we mean by capital the
denominator how do we compute the risk
weights and of course the minimum how
large should ratio B now the proposals
of Basel 3 have already been described
or summarized by mark on the numerator
we will have a more restricted
definition of common equity the
denominator we have higher weights for
trading assets and strike the products
and we have already seen what's going to
happen to the minimum requirements now
what else is he passing 3 just for
reference well there is a leverage ratio
there are the liquidity risks
requirements and then there is this
counter cyclical capital buffer that I
will try to make a brief comment now
what's the procyclical 'ti problem well
I mean what happens in downturns under
reach sensitive regulation is that banks
capital is eroded by losses and non
defaulted borrowers get downgraded and
of course this should lead to an
increase in risk weighted assets which
increases of course
capital requirements so if raising fresh
external capital in bad times is
difficult then banks will be forced to
cut back on the lending and this will
lead to this amplification of business
cycle fluctuation something similar also
happens in good times so let me quote
Charles Goodhart in a recent paper in
the journal of economic literature add
to the procyclical ET of Boston to the
increased adoption of mark-to-market
accounting and you have a perfect
doomsday machine for exacerbating
leveraged cycles I want to come back to
this perfect doomsday machine
and so let's look at the behavior of
risk-weighted assets over the last few
years
well capital requirements are suppose
were supposed to be every sensitive
especially under Basel two so therefore
especially in Europe so let's I want to
look at the ratio of Ridgway that assets
to total assets for example banks in
Europe the UK Switzerland and in the US
I guess that I mean my pretty my
intuition said that well related assets
or assets should have increased
dramatically during the crisis but look
at what happened this is for the banks
in the eurozone well the banks here are
Deutsche Bank Societe Generale
been a paper Reba Commerce Bank I think
is the Italian unique credit and
Santander well I mean could you I mean
look at 2008 I mean if anything came
down the ratio of afraid of a total
asset the QK is similar nothing there
really the Swiss banks are the ones with
the lowest I guess that Wilson will say
something about this every your bank is
the red one here they are I mean look at
the numbers they go from 0 to 90% and
I've taken the average these are the US
banks which are much higher and yours is
the green one JP Morgan and and I've
taken the regional averages doing the
weighted by the assets and well you can
see here that US is at the top although
some people tell me that this is because
of some accounting netting things and
the Swiss banks are the at the bottom
and but the I mean I guess the private
sector people worry very much about the
cross-sectional differ
in these ratios I'm concerned about the
time series behavior the fact that you
couldn't tell from here that something
big has happened in the last few years
during the first worst financial crisis
since the Great Depression the ratio has
remained stable so the perfect doomsday
machine that Charles cooter was
referring to was not perfect at all so
how can we account for this well there
may be some portfolio reallocation that
or safer assets but I think that the
most likely explanation lies is the fact
that a lot of these banks were using
through the cycle approaches to get
these internal ratings and these these
are unconditional assessments of risk
based on an ideal average point of the
business cycle and these unconditional
assessments were accepted and even
encouraged by supervisors now what's the
problem with through the cycle
approaches well basically nobody knows
what it exactly means it are they are
applied differently by different banks
and jurisdictions they open the door to
excesses supervisory discretion and
certainly they introduce this risk of a
level playing field also they violate
the usage test requirement of Basel two
through the cycle ratings ignore
material and relevant information so
they are not useful for pricing of risk
management so they are a disaster
basically and and since you didn't have
the way to adjust the capital
requirements for the cycle then of
course the only way was to do this
cheating now how about the
counter-cyclical buffer which is this
new invention that Basel 3 has
introduced in order to take care of the
cyclical behavior well this is an
extension of the capital conservation
buffer is an initial additional two and
a half percent of his weighted assets
and the problem with the account of
cyclical battery is that the Basel
Committee has chosen as the common
reference point for taking the buffer
decision something called the credit to
GDP gap which is like the output gap but
with credit to GDP ratios what's the
problem with the counter-cyclical buffer
well I mean if you look at how it
correlates with the business cycle like
GD
growth in most countries you have a
negative correlation so that means that
the gap would signal to reduce capital
in good times and would signal to
increase capital in bad times now so
this is a complete disaster
so I have here some correlations using a
IMF data the average for all these six
countries is minus point one of the gap
the second column is the correlation of
the buffer that you construct from the
gap is also negative if you take the
World Bank data then you have even
stronger negative correlations on here
for the US is is negative and this is
for the data comprising the 2009 year so
I have a picture this is what in the UK
which is one of the ones one of the
countries for which these negative
correlation is is stronger and and you
can see the red line is GDP growth the
blue line is a credit to GDP gap and you
see the credit to GDP cap pigs in 2008
and 2009 so this is where you're telling
banks to build more buffers at the time
where you're supposed to be releasing
those buffers to to accommodate the
state of the cycle so what would be the
alternative approach well I've written a
paper with two of my former students
proposing to import the idea of
automatic stabilizers the idea is to use
point-in-time ratings to computer
requirements and then use a multiplier
scaling factor to based on GDP growth to
adjust for the site all the multiplier
would be greater than one in expansion
would be smaller than one in recessions
and in that way
you could try to ameliorate the impact
of the business cycle so let me just
conclude with a few comments I think
that mark is the only person on the
bathroom committee here so this mark
these are for you
so take first it's about what should the
Basel Committee do well I think that the
Basel Committee should explicitly
abandon through the cycle approaches a
point in time I think is the only hope
for Basel 3 in particular the only hope
to sort out the level playing field
issue second comment I think that you
don't explicitly abandoned
Fredi to GDP gap and look for an
alternative reference common reference
without these negative side effects
third I think that you should introduce
a business cycle adjustment to the
minimum requirements this is something
that was pending in the bathroom three
and possibility if nothing better comes
to mind use this multiplier based on GDP
growth I have three more I think that
the bathroom committee should stop
conducting its work in silos the
different risk and the different
regulations are not independent you have
a group of people working on liquidity
regulation as if liquidity had nothing
to do with capital and and then you have
the counter cyclical people doing this
work without looking at what would be
the implication with respect to business
cycle this is a terrible situation I
think that you should get together and
try to put things under the same
analysis I think that the Basel
Committee should seriously engage
academics I think that there are there
are many problems with Basel three you
have basically ignored them perhaps some
of them are very vocal not necessarily
friendly but they are your only hope and
finally and finally I think that at this
point we should put the u.s. in the
driver seat I think that the chair of
the Basel Committee is going to be
appointed in the next few weeks I think
that there is this risk of us drifting
apart you have here dodd-frank and all
the duties that this require I think
that this is a time where the US should
be put in command of these and and
remember that I am a European on this
but but I think that this is yeah I'm
sure but this is badly needed so I urge
mark to convey these to your bosses that
this is the time to make a bid for for
the chair thank you
so we have two microphones just as
before you can direct your questions to
individual members of the panel or you
can put them out there and I'll try to
share them broadly as people are getting
the microphone why don't I start with a
question for my colleagues and if you
can line up behind the microphones to
follow me so at a place like Stanford
we'd probably begin this debate by
saying well what's the framework for a
Prudential supervision how should we be
governed and I think in that framework
we'd say well there should be three
pillars there should be regulatory
discipline that would play an important
role and much of the discussion today
has been about that there's capital
standards and that's a second pillar and
that should play a very important role
in much of the discussion today is about
that now let me add the third pillar
which I think Adrienne will take up with
some discomfort market discipline now
over the crisis I think what we found is
that regulatory discipline fell down
capital standards capital regulation
fell down and yes in fact market
discipline fell down but much of the
discussion today has been about how do I
fix those two pillars as if the
suggestion is you know you can never
trust those markets again well we didn't
say that about regulators and we didn't
say that about capital so is for I'll
ask my colleagues up here is there a
role for market discipline should
information about the banks be more
understood by stakeholders so that they
can help police firms so they instead of
treating the US banks as one entity can
tear them and say I like the risk/reward
of this bank but I don't like the other
or have we decided that market
discipline has lost its place at the
table maybe we can start with you
Adrienne and we'll do a quick round here
before we could take outside questions
well I think that's a that's a I think
that's the tried to side maybe I was
rushing but the the main proposal that
we made at the OECD has been after this
idea of separation that that retail and
commercial banking which is the subject
of explicit and implicit guarantees
shouldn't be are in the same box as
various functions to do with let's call
them Investment Banking
functions for shorthand so if you
separate those off then our market
discipline comes to its fourth for
example if I'm setting up a dealer
relationship with Goldman and they
wanted to put me you know with some
shelf company in the Cayman Islands with
$10 capital you know the back office
says no we won't touch that we want to
access the Goldman's but if you actually
did that and said actually the entity
you're dealing with is separate from
Goldman's it's a separately capitalized
and of course the bid-ask spread is
going to be one of course it's going to
be a much more code of course the cost
of capital is going to go but my
question would be is that a wrong thing
and my my sort of opponent on the on the
desk you would say but that makes it
much harder for us to manage our across
across you know the banks you know all
the different activities we do if you
separate things off it makes it more
complicated but the objective of my of
separation isn't to make it more
comfortable for you know for people to
do their jobs in risk management we
exist the question really is is to make
it Tom to make it such that the cost of
capital that you face is the true cost
of capital and there's no
cross-subsidization from deposit
insurance implicit guarantee is too big
to fail and some you shouldn't be
implicitly putting that into your cost
of capital for other parts of the
business so separation is exactly what
gives you proper market discipline I'm
very happy for the private sector to do
it but not when there's
cross-subsidization
too big to fail retail banking and so on
has to be separated from so adrian was
looking at me but he was talking to you
at him what say you I'm gonna eat my
boomerang yeah I don't I don't think
separation is what would achieve the
desired market discipline I believe that
would make our financial institution
much more opaque not less since
transparency is obviously one of the
issues that people have talked about
enhancing market discipline I think it's
wrong to say that we're not in this but
it's okay to make life more difficult
for the management of risk within an
institution that's precisely the
opposite of what we want to
intend as far as cross subsidization you
know the retail business pays for
deposit insurance but now in the united
states the wholesale business pays for
deposit insurance because it's based on
total liabilities not on deposits so I
think there's a lot to refute what what
what
adrian has to say there if you want to
enhance market discipline I think
because we think there's a very
important role for that
I think disclosure is absolutely
critical to that you know banks annual
reports quarterly reports run into the
hundreds of pages there's a lot of
information there some of it's driven by
the accounting standard setters and the
securities regulators not necessarily
useful I think it's important for bank
management's in their interaction with
the marketplace whether it's through
earnings calls or conferences or
meetings with rating agencies to try to
make them as transparent as possible
there's lots of debt issued by financial
institutions in which the market can
vote with its okay let's turn to
questions I think my cue here is now a
word from our sponsor sound like telling
Steve refrigerators post also from the
Clearing House a question in the context
of the anticipated or proposed
surcharges on Sippy's or Tisa fees and
the question I have of the panel is is
it premature to impose additional
capital requirements on cities or DC
fees when it's pretty clear that no one
really understands the cumulative impact
of the already put in place reforms that
are meant to address too big to fail let
alone Basel 3 capital and liquidity
requirements in and of themselves so if
the panel could comment on the
cumulative impact of all the reforms and
its effect on the banking sector and the
global economy in the context
the proposed sort of surcharges both the
existence of a surcharge and the degree
or quantity of any surcharge
thank you so maybe I'd direct that
question David for you
Moody's obviously has a critical role to
play here in thinking about whether the
capital standards we've talked about
should be supplemented for the
institutions that are deemed in the
language of the moment to be systemic
lis significant for those in the
audience I think one of the theories
behind the global surcharge is that the
largest institutions are whether no
matter how well their risk management
procedures that perhaps they are taking
bigger risks
perhaps they are there are negative
externalities that need to be accounted
for so the insurance cushion should be
higher David what says Moody's on the
subject so many different parts to this
one so yes there are certain
institutions that are systemically
important they in fact the numbers that
were bailed out in number of
institutions available during the crisis
far exceeded our expectations going into
the crisis from my social policy
perspective which is not something
Moody's ever comments on there can be an
argument made for higher bucker
certainly the extent that there is
efforts underway to implement resolution
powers and take actions that rather than
that in the context of bailout would
impose losses on creditors then we will
need to lower our support assumptions
some city buffer for such firms
increasing their capital position could
potentially help to offset so in rating
speak the standalone rating might go up
at the same time the supported rating
goes down that would limit to the
downward pressure but probably would
still be some downward pressure because
it's up all the other factors I cited
you know it's not clear how you measure
the city buffer or what's the rights if
you buffer and now let me make clear we
don't identify what the right number is
so that's the beauty of ratings is
relative ranking I mean we do have to
peg that relative ranking to our default
scale and that so that in some sense yes
there is a rightness to that buffer but
our ratings are relative ranking of risk
so by that definition higher capital is
going to be better but it it can be
viewed in isolation
and that's the challenge we face
everyone faces as everyone knows but
capital is one answer it's not the only
answer capital for a you know domestic
retail deposit-taking local lending bank
is very different than capital for a big
global markets bank with significant
wholesale funding exposures and so but
these things can very hard boil down to
those much I think the other element
which we have been ignoring is there is
the political element you can't ignore
so people are striking while the iron is
hot because at iron is cooling very fast
I've been amazing how much already the
iron is cooling and so that complicates
the whole situation quite dramatically
and makes it difficult to conduct
laboratory experiments
Raphael let me redirect this question to
you so as someone who was pretty
critical of where the Basel three
process is does that suggest that the
question about adding a surcharge to a
weak foundation is ill-timed or is now
the time to get it all fixed well I made
a presentation at the Bank of England
last week in which I referred to the
original scene of bustle - and you're
announcing is that there is no economics
there in the sense that if regulation is
not based on some sort of cost-benefit
analysis of what are they the impact of
this now I am NOT an expert on on sort
of C fees and I haven't thought about
that my hunch is that if you look at the
costs social costs which are associated
with the failure of one of these large
systemic institutions then that suggests
that perhaps they should be a surcharge
for them but I don't have any idea about
the magnitude and certainly I don't know
what paul was referring to the
cumulative impact of all those
regulations because the package has not
been designed in a sort of global way
sort of we don't know I mean for some
banks perhaps these liquidity
requirements are going to be
terrible and so I don't know Adrienne
wants to jump in here then we'll take
another question she needs no it's not
too early to be doing it and the reason
is is because Basel are with the the
port assumption the basic assumption of
Basel is portfolio invariance which is
like a linear additive kind of thing
which doesn't penalize concentration
we're talking here about and I let me
tell you the debate that is on this very
subject is about the question of how do
you sort of get the eyes the notion of
size and concentration and
interconnectedness that that's the
technical difficulty of having one but
the idea that we shouldn't have one now
because it's got somehow covered when we
have a system with portfolio invariance
is the assumption to me there's
definitely the time to have it because
you can have a buffer on the question of
concentration and interconnectedness if
we can define what that is so I think
the summary from this panel one I think
the question is reminds me of the old
saw they were they asked the person at
the restaurant would they think the
person that a restaurant said the food
here is terrible and the portions are
too small next question just read
returning again to the the question too
big to fail and look here the different
perspectives from not from Adam and
Adrian necessarily from Adam and David
so Adam you you taught you extolled the
virtues of of dodd-frank title two and
talking about how if I understood you
correctly it it eliminated the
too-big-to-fail problem for for the
cities I'm intrigued by this in light of
the fact I'm not as familiar with
Moody's own own ratings or the safety is
the same with Standard & Poor's but that
Standard and Poor's has made an explicit
reference to the implicit guarantees
when when evaluating and reading the
debt of these systemically important
financial institutions so the question
is for adamant analysts for David is is
JPMorgan too big to fail and if the
answer is no why do the rating agencies
have that wrong in the ways that they
evaluate that debt and if the answer is
yes then could that be something that
that these equity investors who would be
so resistant to to ratcheting up capital
adequacy would that be something that
they would would enjoy those implicit
guarantees the subsidies from God
that would make the equity investment a
much more lucrative proposition for them
it should definitely answer that
question first
we believe they are systemically
important and we incorporate two notches
about left into our ratings which are
already quite high because they did
demonstrate the stronger risk management
than many of their peers and maintained
a stronger capital position than many of
their peers it will be very difficult to
resolve JPMorgan in a way that does not
create massive systemic risk their role
within clearing system's multiple
different clearing systems not to
mention the rivet of his products is
enormous and frankly this is true for
many large banks around the world and to
tease at all the parts he tease apart
that interconnectedness in a way that
can somehow resolve these institutions
without creating massive contagion he's
extraordinarily challenging I think most
of us here understand that not talking
I'm not talking harrassing people
understand these things but the reality
is will be very difficult to implement
there many many things beyond just
having a resolution power including many
of the other elements of dodd-frank
which may help you know significant
restructuring of the organizations may
be necessary and through the resolution
plans and living wills process to even
get to the point where that could be
done now there's a lot of work on that
being done and we may move in that
direction
but we still have for us as a rating you
can see we still think there's a lot of
uncertainty as to how successful this
will be nonetheless we see downward
pressure because the political rhetoric
is very strong and the the focus of
authorities around the world is we don't
want to pay for this a second time it's
owned by the way we were doing that
we've been incorporating that explicitly
into our ratings for about three or four
years yeah I mean it's a difficult
situation right because you don't want
to prove you're not a witch by drowning
right so you can stop and think about
that for a minute if you'll get it in a
little while
David's exactly right right there's a
ton of work going on through recovery
resolution so-called living will
processes now we've done three
submissions on this with our regulators
it's going to be iterative there's much
more to come where we think about legal
entity structure and how to simplify
that so we run scenarios and try to
wargame if you will
situations of what would happen if you
know we had a certain series of events
and that created funding pressure on the
firm what we would do about
recapitalization proposals we've worked
on white papers which we've shared with
a number of regulators about how to
recap a bank so that you don't
necessarily get to the point of you
actually have to disentangle it so yeah
we're a large global important financial
institution we're proud of that and
we're going to work well with the
regulatory community on these very
issues it's it's not easy but you know
the law of the land in the United States
requires us to move in that direction
and the intent is to make it so that
banks are not too big to fail next
question Wilson and I'm from credit
Swiss so I guess I'm playing the role of
the local Swiss banker you talked for a
little while about the low rwa to gross
assets and one explored that a little
bit with the panel some people have
asserted this is a crazy basel ii
calculation thing and it's true basel ii
is a tough machine it's about a quarter
million calculations so could anybody
possibly understand it but interestingly
we had the same roughly same amount of
capital in Basel 1 and if you look at
those graphs they were about the same in
Basel I and Basel 1 is it
Nihal dame from the Bank of England
pointed out can be done by a competent
clerk with an envelope and a pencil so
it does beg the question of what's going
on here I do think it's as someone who
ran risk for a long time I think it's
very important to risk weight assets I
think not doing that gets you into
actually much bigger trouble than trying
to do it I think it's a necessary evil
if you don't do that you're going to end
up with t-bills counting actually more
than say a CDO swap and that's just
perverse you need to align this better
with markets otherwise so they can get
some very bad properties so my question
is what could we do actually to make
some of these calculations more
comparable more transparent so some of
the pillar 3 aspects could be more
visible to investors and we could
actually bring market discipline which
was one of the original goals of the
Basel framework into play more easily
and just wonder if there any ideas that
the panel has to make that more
transparent to the users risk weighted
assets anyone want to join in on that
Raphael you were somewhat critical of
the judgments being made I I agree with
Wilson and that risk weighted assets are
unnecessarily evil you will hear this
afternoon a proposal to just get rid of
risk weighted assets and just go to or
forget about the weighty because there's
no way which you can do this foolproof
the problem is how you manage that and I
think that my point is that through the
cycle approach which is so popular among
supervisors is is very bad unless you
put the with waiting on a basis that can
be verified and replicated in a simple
way by outsiders then this is going to
be a black box that nobody will
understand so I think that there is a
lot of work to be done by regulators but
it's also a way to be done by the
private sector in trying to sort of look
at how this is done how it should be
done and perhaps agree some sort of
common standards that
we'll allow these to go forward Adrian
wants to jump in then we'll go to Adam
and take the next question yeah I sort
of don't agree with the premises of the
question I think that time you know the
basal system assumes that you know that
there's this acid and that I said and
the risk that it has came down from the
mountains are with the stone tablets and
and that stays at and that stays out and
you risk-weighted and voila but in the
world of complete markets which now
includes banking after you know the
derivative derivatives we didn't have
complete markets in the olders what we
do now you can just shifter so what is
the financial system the financial
system is just the system of promises
you go back to the wild west though you
just write a promissory note it's a
system of promises if you have a system
where derivatives can be used to shift
those promises around to wherever the
lowest common denominator is because we
do not have a level playing field
if you can just ship the promises around
risk weighted assets let you do that and
that's what they do and that's why those
graphs look like that so shake your head
but that's the truth to me there's no
such thing as ex-anti buckets of risk
because you can always transform things
look at the numbers for the actual banks
in the world and check how those trends
have been over time and when Basel 2 is
implemented I think actually will so two
again together wilson's try to get at
wilson's question and I think Darrel you
and Gary Gorton may have done some work
that says hey capital may not be the
best predictor of distress here in fact
it could it's likely to be elite a
lagging indicator I think we saw that in
the financial crisis of somewhat of a
lagging indicator and that there are
other measures that we ought to be
looking at Wilson which might help us
here and this is where AJ and I can
agree with you I think concentration is
an excellent point you know we see this
all the time Bank
why do banks fail largely because they
get conned
traded in a particular type of asset
class and that blows up somehow and they
can't withstand it because the market
loses confidence there goes their
funding the capital isn't there and
they're done and I think that's a great
point and we should we should definitely
look at that asset quality measures
ought to be scrutinized intensively as
predictors of financial performance so I
think there there are metrics out there
I think banks put a lot of information
out there perhaps we can do a better job
we can maybe some academic research
could be done about other predictive
measures of bank financial performance
and risk performance to supplement on
capital I don't know that you could ever
actually get Wilson through a pillow
three type disclosure into the gory
details of actually how you know a PD
LGD was actually determined because it
just it would be too much information to
digest in market risk we've advocated
the use of test portfolios to get behind
what our power models capturing the risk
attributes of a particular portfolio we
think that's critical it'd be hugely
informative to supervisors they ought to
use it as checks on each other for peer
reviews we'd be all in support of that
let's take care our next question yeah
I'm Jonathan Burke I'm a professor here
at GSB one of the advantages of being a
professor is you get to take a step back
every now and again so I'm gonna ask you
a question which is really to force you
guys to take a step back the question is
this how can somebody earning $100,000 a
year possibly regulate somebody earning
ten million dollars here let me give you
some background if you look at the
discussion today you will see all the
regulator's said essentially the same
thing which was there was a problem with
the current
occupation and here's how you fix it
ignoring the fact that when the current
regulation was written those very people
were saying there was a problem with the
previous regulation here's how we gonna
fix it and we never gonna have the
problem again okay and avian goes back
takes whatever you guys rides okay and
then figures out how to make the most
amount of money he can which inevitably
which inevitably leads to undermining
the regulation so let's go back to the
question how is it possible for people
earning hundreds of thousands of dollars
a year to regulate people earning ten
million dollars a year so it's a it's a
question that I think's been hanging
over this group for a while let me
invite my colleagues to jump into it I
would suggest that one answer is to not
rely solely the well-intentioned
good-faith wisdom of regulators alone to
be the policeman I would suggest that
regulators need some means to look over
the mountain around the corner and one
means to do that is to get market prices
to start helping them market prices
can't help them if people that are
bidding on those prices think these
institutions are effectively backed by
their governments so one mental end
exercise as my colleagues get ready to
answer this is look at the ten K or 10 Q
and financial ports of a consumer
products company look at the financial
statements of Walmart or Procter &
Gamble spend a couple of hours and see
if you understand that business and what
the risks are to them financially seems
not an impossible task pull out the 10 K
or 10 Q of a large systemically
significant financial institution in
Japan in Switzerland and Germany in
France in the US and try that same
exercise even with the expertise in this
room and you end up with a far less on
clear understanding and so doing markets
are perhaps not helping regulators look
around the corners as best they could
but I turn it to my colleagues to try to
answer that question
Raphael should we start with you I think
that this is not unique to
and banking regulations think of
taxation on me you have corporate tax
lawyer earning the 10 million and maybe
you have the poor guy working at the
Treasury or the IR yes trying to sort of
see through these so I mean this is a a
broader thing related to public sector
and how it relates to the private sector
and I think that I agree with Kevin that
there is a something that can be said on
his argument but I would like to argue
that there is something called sort of
public service I think that's how people
sort of like to spend their lives
instead of working in this type of field
and perhaps we should rely more on this
type of ability of a willingness of
people to do that kind of job but I I
don't have a good answer to your
question Adam and I were classmates
together and we went to the Fed together
in in New York after graduate school
precisely for that reason we were
interested in public service and we
didn't think we were well at least in
David's case he was as smart as any
banker that was out there definitely not
in my case but his in his case you know
he was committed to public service there
are high quality people in regulatory
agencies they're not unlike any other
corporate type entity where you have a
distribution of talent and you know I
don't think it's purely a matter of
money you have very dedicated people who
committed to that endeavor is it a
challenge yes I think cross
pollenization would be good having
regulators come in actually spend some
time in a financial institution and go
then look at another one to avoid
conflicts I think that's I know in
France they've tried that I think that's
a very good discipline but I don't think
it's a purely a matter of numbers you
have institutional frameworks you have
you know what well-intentioned and well
thought-out people I have a question for
you in return
how do I get to wear jeans and a tucked
out shirt to an event like this you get
tenure at stamps was your response
because I guarantee you on the
compensation committee at Morgan
you would never argument you would never
argue well we'll rely on the fact that
people are publicly spurred to the words
government towards JP Morgan we would we
would it's not you know it's nice to
think about people's being publicly
spiritual and it's nice to think that we
all act the way we do but we know that
fundamentally people aren't motivated
that way on you know at a very base
level so when you've got a somebody
earning a couple hundred thousand or
somebody earning ten million
we know where the incentives the person
with the 10min it has all the incentives
to work really really hard and worsen it
to hire the very best brains to
undermine whatever regulations were
written I think if we just proceed with
saying well that doesn't happen if
people don't behave that way no I think
that's how we give up saying I don't
think I was saying that I think that all
I was saying is that the pay that the
Federal Reserve pays which is very good
relative to society in general they're
very competent strong people there's an
institutional framework that supports
them there are laws and regulation that
provide the foundation for what they do
could they improve their talent
absolutely would it be better if they
had more money to pay people to attract
as rich talent as I could
yeah that would be helpful too but it's
not like they're without talent or with
it they're out but they're in unable to
do their their jobs I just I don't find
that adrian wants to get in quickly then
we've got three minutes we'll try to do
lightning round questions go ahead well
I I think I sort of agree with your
question intaglio or the sense of it I
think you know when you've got it for
everyone
go for the gold is always a part of
their lifetime objective and
unfortunately regulatory capture one of
the elements of regulatory capture is
that the person on 100k is always
through his career in a sense taking a
job interview before when he transfers
across to go for the gold and that makes
it very very hard
in that process we've got time for two
final quick questions we'll start here
yeah my question is in two parts one has
to do with to what extent oh my name is
Monique Academy with cyprus praxis how
do you account for public confidence and
trust in what you do and number two it
this is again related to this business
of the banking sector and finance sector
is supposed to from professor horns
class allocate capital and savings to
the real world and real economy so some
degree I mean that whole focus has got
to be on how we do in the real economy
and the extent to which they incentive
for bankers has gotten I mean from the
perspective of some of us skewed where
the incentives don't have much to do
with the real economy but have more to
do with the banking and finance sector
so people who are involved in the
finance sector basically get a lot more
in compensation that teachers and people
who provide labor and who provide real
goods and services to most people so
this is not directly to what you're
talking about but it's really the bigger
context for what we do in an institution
to be able to push some back in terms of
our existing points of view and see if
any of them loosened so that's the
second part of my question it has to do
with whether you are aware whether you
agree whether you question among
yourselves whether the banking and
finance sector has an ordinance greater
amount of power and Society in our
political system even in the regulatory
environment as well as in our economy
anyone want to try to do that quickly
I think those are both tough and hard
questions adrian promises he can answer
them both soundly in 30 seconds we're
gonna take a final question here after
it would just quickly be you know the
fundamental asset that i spoke of in
that gray line now that funds real
activity and investment you saw that you
know the derivatives which accounts for
a lot of our remuneration and employing
people has been growing exponentially
over time
let's just say that that period from
1998 to today isn't a period that covers
itself with glory in terms of economic
growth in the real economy a great final
question very very quick then Moody's
just threatened to lower US government's
reading if debt ceiling and presumably
revisits us it wasn't handled what do
you all think how serious is this it was
directed it's a question about the
forthcoming debt limit directed our
Moody's College certainly we've been
pretty consistent what we've been saying
which is the US government has a deficit
challenge to address that challenge the
short-term issues about the debt ceiling
are just heighten that challenge but
frankly if a government decided for
whatever reason to default on its
obligations even on a temporary basis
then we would need to reflect that in
the race presumably various on the panel
has been thinking about this particular
issue too so I wonder if we could hear
your general thoughts on debt ceiling
u.s. deficit lowering ratings what this
might do to what you'll do so I'm
looking at the look of my colleagues
here and they feel ill prepared to
answer that but but but we appreciate
those two final questions those are both
frankly worthy of panel discussions both
with respect to the fiscal
sustainability of the economy in the
u.s. the costs and obligations
associated with the financial crisis
that have no doubt added to the burdens
the last question spoke to as well as I
think a broader question that was raised
about whether the time and attention and
financial resources that have gone into
the financial services sector is bearing
fruits on the real side of the economy
with that let me on behalf of all of you
thank my colleagues for joining me today